let's follow up about school lunch this
story is just vile we've talked about
republicans and school lunch before
the news is that mitch mcconnell
is reportedly again opposing free school
lunch
um
the washington post reports that mitch
mcconnell is opposing an extension to
the free school lunch program this comes
as congress is deciding what to include
in the upcoming government funding
package you may recall
that again we are in the situation where
the free school lunch the comprehensive
free school lunch program that was
started and expanded during the pandemic
has an expiration date on it
and now
there are
republican lawmakers including mitch
mcconnell
who oppose including that
in a new government funding package
uh i have to tell you that this is one
of the most vile things like you really
have to
understand
the degree to which these people cannot
empathize with anybody else and we've
talked about opposition to free school
lunch from the right wing before
remember this clip from october where
fox news anchor martha mccallum is like
listen if kids think school lunch is
free then
i guess something very bad would happen
one of the things that kills me is that
now that you know there's a free lunch
program in new jersey and it's for
everyone even if you you don't need help
to send your child's lunch to school so
those kids are all gonna grow up
thinking well school is lunch is free
right and then god help the person who
comes along and tries to take that away
these kids might grow up thinking school
lunch is free in
why shouldn't it be why shouldn't it be
in a literal sense
of course food's not free you understand
this i understand this it's a you know
people pay property taxes and it funds
schools
and you're paying for school lunch
sometimes property taxes include trash
pickup the trash pickup isn't literally
free
it's paid for through your property tax
okay
sometimes
it's good
when we pay for things with taxes and
sometimes it's not so good so for
example many of us would say i don't
love that my taxes without any option i
mean okay you know we could replace
everybody to end the military industrial
complex and only elect people who won't
support it in any way it's not realistic
that that's going to happen overnight i
don't necessarily love tax money going
to some of the weapons that it goes
towards okay fine when we're talking
about school lunch first of all
it's so cheap
it's so cheap secondly it's really
stigmatizing a lot of schools still have
this colored lunch ticket program at my
elementary school you know 90 years ago
um
if you paid full price for lunch you got
a green ticket
and if you got the discounted lunch you
got a yellow ticket and if you got
free lunch you had i think it was like a
red ticket or whatever it's
extraordinarily stigmatizing to do that
in elementary schools in a way that can
be really damaging to kids and when they
say it we can't have kids growing up
thinking that it's free if property
taxes cover school lunch
what's the big devastating realization
that kids will come to it's just oh the
lunch is free
we pay for it through property taxes oh
all right well i understand it school is
mandatory you have to be there but they
don't have to give you food at no
additional cost at the point of purchase
your you have to be there and your
property taxes pay for it there are kids
depending on the school lunch in order
to eat and republicans
don't want to do it either because they
say we can't afford it because we
obviously can or because they think that
children are going to be taught some bad
lesson is it a good thing to be thinking
that
uh
if you're a kid in school to be thinking
that whether i eat
depends on
anything other than just am i here can
my parents afford it or not did mitch
mcconnell extend the program or not oh
well you get lunch and you don't
it's absurd it's absurd and of course
it's not even really free it's just
prepaid that's really all that we're
talking about and when you step back
if you are a politician and you think
so-called free school lunch is a problem
then you're not even in the right
universe you're not even in the right
galaxy when thinking about the problems
that we have and mitch mcconnell now
joining the train and saying no no no no
we can't allow this to happen school
lunch should just be free period and by
free i mean prepaid
through property taxes as it already is
but for everybody rather than just some
people